yeah well in fact we did a lot uh during
those years I can remember being in
government when we sent Commissioners in
to Rotherham to take over the local
Authority there that was the
accumulation of a spiral of problems a
spiral of Silence if you like and
fundamentally not believing the victims
of these terrible crimes if you remember
K you know 10 or so years ago we were
still really grappling with a culture
where young women were just not being
taken seriously they were being
stigmatized themselves as uh
um somehow involved or complicit with
this behavior and their evidence just
wasn't was being marginalized now I I
think that that culture is changing I I
think um we've still got a way to go I
can remember doing cases uh solicitor
general in the latter part of the decade
where I was talking about making sure
that when you had Asian or South Asian
gangs targeting white uh victims at the
courts uplifted the sentences because
frankly there was a racial element to
that criminality of course it cuts I
think always this isn't a uh something
that's all about just one ethnic group
it should cover everybody and the
important message was being sent out by
me and others that abuse is abuse there
is no excuse for cultural reasons uh
so-called cultural reasons to get in the
way of what is child abuse plain and
simple
here but having said that I know that
the prime minister is going to be
banging on about political correctness
later on but you know if you look at the
figures there are more white men than
Asian men that are responsible for the
grooming of young people
yeah well that's why I said that this
Cuts all ways and I think it's wise Kate
to focus on on the victims themselves to
make sure that uh predominantly young
women are being listened to are being
supported and that their evidence is
being taken seriously that was the heart
of the problem some years ago in in the
communities that we are well familiar
with uh and uh you know in an age where
evidence can be taken by a pre-recorded
uh means by even cross-examination now
done in a pre-recorded way you know
victims of crime must know that their
their voice will be heard that they will
be taken seriously and they will be
marginalized because of who they are
where they've come from you know a young
girl in care her voice is just as
important as as anybody else's in our
society and it needs to be heard in
order to expose some of the horrific
criminality that we see in the form of
these organized grooming gangs just
another thought if I may and then I have
other topics to discuss with you
um similar bravman apparently said that
labor turned a willful Blind Eye to
grooming gangs when they were in power
Lisa nandi the shadow leveling up
secretary yesterday called Ms Braverman
a joke for saying that do you think she
overstretched there
well look I I think that everybody needs
to take responsibility for perhaps a
time when there were a so-called
cultural sensitivities that were
predominating and taking precedence over
the need to follow the evidence wherever
it leads
um I think all of us should take
responsibility for that I think there
was a problem I mean rather it was years
and years of problems being piled upon
each other which began long before 2010.
well no I don't I don't think we should
get we should make this a party
political thing frankly I think we
should be focusing on the victims of
crime recognizing that there are have
been times in our past where uh you know
for whatever reason cultural
sensitivities have been uh put first and
foremost and that's wrong abuse is abuse
we should call it out wherever it comes
from whoever does it uh we need to
listen to the victims of crime and sure
they're supported that that's always
been my Approach follow the evidence and
follow it to wherever it leads without
fear or favor
what's to blame for the queues at Dover
do you think
well I think um for my Layman's eye
looking on uh it does seem that there's
a a a a Confluence of issues I think
that there's no doubt that some of the
increased checks that now are necessary
since we left the EU will be a part of
that
um I think that
um all the authorities on both sides of
the channel both the French and the
British authorities have to work even
harder to make sure that those short
straights are working as effectively as
possible at times of maximum pressure
you know it should be no surprise to
anybody that we've hit the Easter
holiday season we're gonna have lots of
school parties we've got lots of
families wanting to travel and it does
seem to me to be
um somewhat of a a problem here that
this uh this particular backlog what was
allowed to grow I gather the things of
of ease somewhat overnight but uh
putting myselves in the shoes of those
families and businesses it must have
been horrendous over the last few days
and the authorities has got to work even
harder to make sure that we minimize
repeats of this type of blockage
have you I wonder how I might be able to
ask you about a review that you're
launching to autistic people at work
could you tell us any more about that
yes yesterday I launched a review it's
an independent review but it's on behalf
of the government to look at the
obstacles which stand in the way of far
too many autistic people in order to get
jobs only about two out of 10 adults
autistic adults are in employment at the
moment that I think that's a
ridiculously low figure bearing in mind
the potential of people with Autism
we're going to be working with business
with industry to identify a best
practice to work out the the best ways
in which obstacles to the Recruitment
and Retention of autistic people can be
overcome and I'm looking forward to
working with the government and indeed
with the with the charity sector and
indeed with with the wider economy in
order to release the potential of
autistic people this isn't just a
morally white case k this is good for
our economy good for productivity and an
important part of reducing so-called
economic inactivity that is that is a
real issue that is concerning the
government at the moment so I'll be
working on that through the summer and
I'm looking forward to the tasks ahead I
wonder if you've seen the front page of
the Daily Mirror today if not swella
bravaman has claimed nearly 25
000 pounds in five years for her London
home while living rent free with her
parents when not there now it's not
against the rules but it's stretching
them to the absolute limit especially
when people are struggling so much to
try and pay their bills at the moment
what do you say what would you say about
that
okay I hadn't seen that headline I don't
know the facts of that case
um I I don't think I can comment without
knowing any more I'm afraid well I can
tell you that her people have agreed
that that um has indeed been the case
they offered a defense as you would
expect but I mean the Optics are not
good when something like that happens
are they
well I think all of us in public life uh
when we have the uh privilege of
representing people in Parliament uh
have a duty to make sure that we spend
taxpayers money as wisely as possible uh
you know MPS of offices to run I think
people accept that that needs to be won
uh properly with supporting staff
um I I for instance share share
accommodation London with another MP try
and keep costs down uh I think all of us
need to be very mindful of the fact that
at this time of pressure for many
families we should do our bits to keep
costs as effective as possible and as
low as possible